it's a film that's this role and the
emotions need to be shared and the more
people they're sharing it the more
hiking this whole thing is it's just I'd
go to remote people go to have this
shared kind of yeah we're here for it
now give it to us new in theaters this
weekend glass this is your weekend
ticket
[Music]
the third installment of the unbreakable
series is finally here following the
original unbreakable that came out in
2000 and split out of 2016
glass is the continuation of the
superhuman story of the overseer the
beast and mr. glass Bruce Willis James
McAvoy and Samuel Jackson all returned
for more superhero drama what do you
want I am here to see if tales of the
extraordinary B are true may I meet the
beasts primary relevance
I need your abilities to get us all out
of here this movie is for you if you
love the original two films of the
series if you're a fan of M night
Shyamalan take on superhero stories or
you feel Bruce James and Samuel would
make the perfect boy band
that is your weekend ticket check back
next week for a dose of McConaughey and
Hathaway oh and did you hear Matthew
McConaughey lost his entire left side
don't worry though he's alright alright
alright wait didn't we already use that
in a previous episode
did you hear Matthew McConaughey lost
his entire left side it's okay though
he's alright alright alright I was
twenty eight who cares
[Music]